all right hey guys what's up welcome to
date fails I'm Kate Quigley I am so
excited to be here doing an episode
today with two of my very good friends
first of all both of you are beautiful
it's shocking to me that we're all
single like one of us should have
managed to trap a man you know what I'm
capable of yeah I know happy hours yeah
all right well we all have a little
psycho in us sometimes we have a bigger
psycho well anyway let me introduce my
guest today so let's start over there on
the end with the other lovely blonde in
the room you and I have been friends for
a very long time she's a very funny
comedian and writer and also hosts a
podcast I've been a guest on and I love
which is called white wine true-crime
Cary Martin everyone carry your podcast
is so dope so basically their podcast is
they have comics come over and drink
wine and watch crime TV shows and then
analyze the show and basically make fun
of it is that am I getting it right in a
nutshell that's it for the most part
it's wine there are times when we will
have vodka there's times when I've taken
muscle relaxers and half the time the
comics don't drink so it's mean my
co-host Catelynn getting progressively
drunker which was really fun to watch
her it's a train wreck I had a blast I
had a blast doing that show we watched
an episode about a tweeker couple they
were both methods and they had kids and
they were trying to but I think
refinance their home people who don't
want to cry
you don't watch true crime was just
totally fine after no well wait no I
watch crime shows but not that specific
that's a specific show right no that's
what you said the day of the podcast too
and then you asked if it had Matthew
McConaughey in it and no yeah genre I
was disappointed on the investigation
Discovery Channel it's okay we had fun
but it's about cry I love crime shows i
watch more saturated i watch like
criminal mom pretty stuff that's why
Annabelle and I
here we like to bond over Bachelorette
and Real Housewives uh-huh yeah crying
my watch is like Brooklyn nine-nine it
was like they're policemen like jails
the other night I'm gonna introduce you
in a second but the other day I was
driving to a gig and San Miguel and we
drove by a prison I'm not sure what
prison I
fullsome maybe I don't know what's on
the way we drove by a prison and it
didn't occur to me that I had turned on
my tinder because I was tindering
along the drive and all of a sudden I'm
tindering up all these guys I'm like man
these guys look like they just got out
of jail like these guys look dark and
then might be like bad boys yeah my
buddy Jackson is like well you know
there's a prison like a mile away like
they probably did just get out of jail
I'm like I have no one didn't help and I
can fix them and they'll never leave me
oh my life I should introduce and about
I'm so excited you're here first of all
I'm so happy to be here thank you for
having me yeah of course you are so
funny
your stand-up is so funny well I got
what I needed I can leave I don't even
play it every day you are there like
your Twitter is so funny your stand-up
it's somebody I remember the first time
I ever saw you do you remember when we
may start we're in the belly room and
she came in and like my head like I feel
like I'm like a frat guy as soon as I
know that there's like a hot young girl
with like great boobs it's like I I just
sense it's like a sixth sense where it's
like my head like whipped around because
somebody was like performing was in the
front row and I was being like very rude
because I'm more excited to see a hot
girl than I am to see like a hot guy
right anyway I'm I'm straight is it
because you're very attractive
I just I get so excited I'm like I like
to see their makeup I love to see their
outfits I just yeah you're like yeah
it's going to ensue but it's not cool
yeah I mean it's like I'm not like she
eats for drugs then she books yeah it's
something I'm not gonna go to a [ __ ]
Museum I'm not that intelligent but it's
like looking at like an art piece oh my
god you're too kind
thank you I remember that because back
then I was doing comedy dressed like
really cute so I went on stage that
night in like a little midriff top and a
short skirt my hair is only in cowboy
boots I have my makeup done and I I
don't normally look like that on stage
but I remember that night because you
came up to me and you said something
about who I looked like I can't even
remember now like you looks like a very
like sexy edgy like Carrie Underwood
like look at me like thank you like
hurry underway to have like a
personality and it was very you know
yeah thank you well and then you went on
stage and I was like holy [ __ ] this girl
is funny you kind of almost play okay
well first of all Annabelle desist oh I
should introduce her Annabelle desist oh
very funny comedian and writer and you
have a blog I didn't even I haven't I
apologized I haven't had a chance to see
it because I didn't even know Hey I mean
it's like it's like second to HuffPo
it's pretty big but um it's Motel and
compliments which is my favorite name
I've ever I love a dural and Gaiman so I
decided to name it after my favorite
foods it was like what are my favorite
things in life besides myself and cat so
funny the other day my friend is like
why don't you have an Amazon wish list
you have to have one you know all I want
is compliments I don't need things
I just need people to be like I love you
and I feel that's all I need that's
right I need the validation that's
really it but Carrie you said you've
read her blog and you love the blog yes
I knew that Annabelle has done comedy
and unfortunately I haven't seen it I
happen to be you can get a scalper
that's great but so I don't I don't you
know fault you for not it's hard to get
it okay there's a line it's like
Hamilton it's you know sold out I'm a
black rapper yeah she your material is
so funny because she almost dies I don't
wanna say it's a character cuz you
really are like this in real life to
some degree but you amp it up on stage
and you you basically almost play like a
spoiled Beverly Hills brat but in a way
that's so unapologetic about it it's
absolutely hilarious like I don't even
like even repeat your material but the
first time I ever saw her I mean she's
blatantly racist on stage but like
unapologetic
we are off stage on stage you want to be
honest and I'm just an [ __ ] people
are like you know that characters so
mean I was like yeah that character I
was like dude if anything those are the
nicest things I have to say like oh that
characters so mean it's like I was like
I think I'm so nice on a date I can't
imagine like I can't say that this will
be like my family-friendly you know that
he'll like oh that was a imagine if you
actually said like everything that you
thought I would have been shot by now
yeah but so Carrie you read the blog I
did I did I was telling Annabelle and in
the hallway it was one of those where
yeah it had a late late night there the
night before and I was like I'm
definitely not working out so I'm either
watching Netflix or I'm reading in bed
and I happened upon her blog on Facebook
and I watched The Bachelorette and this
is a good season and so I popped on it
to read it and it was one of the
funniest things I've ever read I
literally spent the next probably three
or four hours binge reading it oh wow
yeah going back to her old episodes and
then I started reading about sander pump
rules
I loved her style and if you guys get a
chance to read it that means so much to
me I don't like reading a tweet oh my
god like a lot of pictures that's
important is a lot of pictures are it is
funny because I tweet a lot of jokes
more jokes than anything and people will
complain it me I actually have a few
people who have tweeted at me and been
like enough with the words already like
so now some time also said two girls
oops
enough of that yeah a little mermaid
enough with the words just you know
seriously unbelievable well you know
what's funny about that is I've been
trying to do some material onstage about
that because I recently dated a porn
star yeah does that big mistake big
mistake folks at home not a great idea
to date a porn star I can handle someone
who had more credits than me
that's well can you think that and then
you watch their work and you're like oh
but they can't act and it's like that
hurts but but I I realized that the
reason I can't do it it's not even
him having sexual other girls in a weird
way like that kind of almost made me
feel good cuz I'm like oh he's [ __ ]
so many girls at work you probably won't
even like try to like pick up random you
know what I mean like I was happy about
it but what I didn't like is the balance
of power is off because think about it
like with a normal guy if he's being
kind of a dick you're like oh yeah guess
what you ain't getting none tonight I'm
going home and they then there we come
we had no no no I'm sorry I'm sorry I'll
try harder I'll text you tomorrow I'll
call you it's my fault it's all my fault
that doesn't work on a pornstar because
they're like cool you want to leave
I got a 7:00 a.m. call time three girls
can be sucking my dick in the morning so
it doesn't so then all you can take away
is your personality see I don't have
that problem I think I just ate the
worst guys in the world I say I'm gonna
leave and they're like could I walk you
to your car I have this happen once and
I was like no you don't have to knit
goes no I need to get my guest parking
pass really usually if I'm at a guy's
place and I'm threatening to leave
before the sex they will find some way
to try to convince you to stay because
they want the sex you must be really
good at it at the sex at the sax thank
you I've never had a complain about the
sex but I don't know if I'm like a pro
and I'll be honest if you're airing your
dirty laundry we're pretty good friends
yeah it wasn't just one your dirty
laundry is just it wasn't just one start
store it all right well no tell me I'm
sorry
okay Kerry thank you I told this on
stage last night so I guess all right I
had a bad date fail I had the worst day
for this is so embarrassing by the way I
just want to go on the record to say
that I don't hook up a lot and I'm not
the kind of girl to just bring home porn
stars am I the kind of girl I don't hook
up a lot do i hook up a lot I don't I I
hook up with guys I like typically but
it's just that I believe you know but
that's well yeah what we do we have to I
do because I don't down the mortgage
Judy calls now I have three cats so I
don't have to I said that takes a hair
so I don't really have any problems
because no one is calling me so I don't
have a pretty you don't have a booty
call that you that you keep on the line
for when you're really really horny and
you want to hook up no I'm like close
thing to a booty call it's like when I
accidentally sent my phone tonight
yeah I don't like I would say I wish I
did I wish I was at home I've not had
them so many times and I've just
recently tried to keep them but I only
can have them if I don't like them I can
only only keep them for defects like a
stud pony I have one okay I have two
actually now that are on call like but I
really like I can only have you as a
booty call if I can't stand you to the
point where I would never date you but
you're really hot so and they don't last
for very long because I do get bored of
the sex if I'm not into them into them
but yeah I have a couple that I will
call but so alright there's a porn star
yeah
not the one I was dating a different
porn star this model another model guys
you know actors and NFL players - porn
stars now like I took a bigger town all
of it and I have some stories so there's
a porn star who's actually super hot and
Kerri seen him naked and he's smart
actually and he's funny and so we
started kind of talking and and then we
kind of worked together on something
ironically he was on an episode of my TV
show and then we just kept in touch but
like more as friends I was like growing
him out but then he started kind of
flirting and then we started talking
about hanging out and then I was like
maybe I'll go out with him you know I
wasn't going to because I dated the
one porn star and I felt bad about it
but then that porn star turned out to be
like hooking up a tons of chicks that I
found out about so like whatever why not
so I said we could go out so he's like
cool I'll come over after work
so I'm my great perfect time so he comes
over he gets off work at like 4:00 he
calls me at like 4:45 he's like I'm on
the way do you mind if I come in and
take a shower real quick because I
didn't get a shower after work so I make
sure come on in
so it comes in he takes a shower and
then I'm like so what do you want to do
where do you want to go and he's like I
wanna [ __ ] you yeah and I'm like what I
thought you wanted to go out and like do
something and like we can go like oh why
don't we go get food are you hungry and
he's like yeah I'd love to eat your
[ __ ] great yelp review again as a
disclaimer knowing Kate for so long she
tells me so many stories about guys
wanting to eat her ass I don't ever had
anyone offer or try I've only seen this
I don't think of regular people maybe a
lot of a shut-in if somebody wanted to
do that I would it would and it's not
it's not a judgmental thing always like
the app so I'm not judging people who do
it I know this is going to sound
hypocritical but if I wanted it I'd be
like oh no and we I can never and I'm
definitely not and I will drown myself
in Listerine and you can please go and
please tell me what cups you use so I
can throw them out like I know I think
it's normal I'm probably just like a
Mormon no but I mean I get it cuz I feel
I am Mormon it could be just because of
my job now maybe with my show about all
the sex stuff
it's everything just seems tame to me or
maybe it's cuz I read Fifty Shades of
Grey
I don't know I think you're the norm I
think that you're like oh
cosmoGirl of what you know it's 2016
owning your second no I think that's the
norm okay well thank you just not
everybody has the luxury of people
wanting to do it to them exactly oh you
should let someone it's great people are
begging and you know I'll just pick a
lucky I'm almost like I'm past my prime
know what about getting a breast
reduction I'm like what there's nothing
anyone yes there is
although carry me every time i periscope
with you like 20 guys or like she has
great tits so I don't know if I'd mess
with them maybe it's like the last
redeeming thing I've got left
hold on to it like bloody talent you
have great before I finish this porn
star No can we come back just for one
second to show weight has no guy ever
asked Carrie yeah I think though it's
like self-conscious cuz I'd be like oh
my god like I'm like what do you want to
do that why the freak if I let you wait
for asking I got it I'd rather just like
I would think it was a joke I just
really liked it so when I have sex I
make sure that that everything is very
clean I mean like I'm crazy about that
is crazy all these like good-looking
guys and like really good about hygiene
guys don't judge me it's like oh these
are great things that you should just be
like a freak at nobody wants you might
ask so I'm Jeff I bathe once a week so
he's only hungry for my ass I am in a
dilemma now okay because in my mind I
don't thought yeah I thought that this
guy wanted to date me I thought he was
interested in me he's called me many
times we facetimed so I'm like thought
he was into my personality but now he's
very sick like Colleen calling and
facetiming right I think that's like I
see I would think that's very Davey is
serious like a dating thing when my
phone rings I'm like it's Kate or my mom
someone's dead yeah that's nice
right guys all I'm like oh my god
they're really into you if they call you
you're sure yeah because it's just you
talking so I click on rings sometimes
I'm like what's that noise
Gary Gulman he's like your phone isn't
even a phone your phone is an app that's
on your device that you never yes that's
but anyways so so now I'm like alright
well I have two options cuz he obviously
doesn't want to date me I was wrong so I
can either kick him out but he's a
really hot porn star he's in my house
and I haven't had sex in like a month or
whatever so like you know I think I
might just [ __ ] him I think I'm gonna
[ __ ] him and I'm gonna see how it is and
it might be great material and so we do
it we have the sex we have the sax that
sex is good you know it's fine it's
great he has a great dick whatever but
then after the sex he's like you know
I'm actually I'm kind of hungry now can
we go get food he's like it's got to be
somewhere quick cuz I got another scene
at 8 o'clock gotta go back to work
somebody else
oh you can't know so I'm like alright
where do you want to go he's like can we
go to Chipotle and I'm like oh my god
this is the most embarrassing has ever
happened to me like I just [ __ ] a guy
that got one to date me and now we're
going out to dinner at Chipotle before
you go so [ __ ] someone else
it's like bass and that's really nice
today I'm gonna go eat Chipotle right
he's like I had seen I just say Chipotle
alright let's do this to the front of
the line we'd get our food and then he's
like hey yo you got this one I'm a
little tight on cash so I didn't know
what to do so I paid for our burritos so
basically what I'm telling you is I paid
a porn star to [ __ ] me with a Chipotle
burrito and I did I paid for the burrito
and then I wish that was the end of the
story cuz that's pretty much the most
pathetic thing that it's ever happening
in my life yet then we sit down to eat
the burrito and when I didn't mention
cuz it's gross and really embarrassing
this is so embarrassing Carrie I'm gonna
kill you it's a good story
so when we were having the sex he was
like I really want to come on your face
and I was like well you know you're a
porn star so you cake okay good aim
you're like you're a professional you
seem like you got Wow Wow porn stars get
up and you don't even know it Annabelle
yeah because I'm like try to get it in
my mouth my eyes and I open my mouth
look at me on the line potentially
blinded you know so we're sitting at
Chipotle like halfway through the
burrito my eye starts like it's really
something he's like babies pregnant the
next day we were talking on the phone
and she was you got an ID and have to
flush out or I cuz it was red the next
day she's right that's a great tag cuz
I'm gonna do this on stage thank you I'm
driving the next day to a meeting and my
eye is swelling and watering so bad I
can't see I had to pull over the car
I'm calling Kari I'm like I can't see my
eyes I don't know me to come get you
and then jen is texting me she's like
you need to go to the hospital my GU
regular target
you went to the hospital in the valley
they're like Oh again same [ __ ] as
always one dollar sign the best part is
at lunch when I'm like like you came in
my eye and he's like that's kind of hot
do you feel like a porn star I was like
no I feel like you feel like a porn dude
I feel like a porn star no really really
[ __ ] but yes yeah I do feel like a
porn star the other thing to watch me in
so many different my god here's the best
part of it whereas we're leaving he's
like he's like 27 minutes I go what he
goes science I'm so he's a timing how
long I [ __ ] from working in porn that I
actually look at my watch when I start
it's a bad habit I'm like you know
exactly how long we [ __ ] words like 27
minutes I was like that's disappointing
before a run it's been exactly 27
minutes it's so something similar like
that happened to one of my friends at
her bachelorette party she had it in
Mexico which is stupid oh thank god
afterwards she got a crab in her eye
what had to go to the doctor the pubic
like a like a little hmm and had to wear
an eyepatch for a while I thought it
would be funny and I suggested this to
you that you be the comic in a bikini
with an eyepatch dude the best part is I
had a date the next day or like this
really nice guy that I've been seeing
and so I had to text him on the way and
go hey I don't want to cancel but just
so you know I was at a barbecue
yesterday and something flew in my eye
and it's really swollen I'm gonna go to
the doctor I might be wearing an
eyepatch and he's so sweet he's like put
a hot compress on it Kate you're that
beautiful and funny and like that you
are the only girl who could pull off an
eyepatch words like even if you had no
eyes you are the only person you could
like pull off an eyepatch if you would
be like oh that should be a John run
like you porn oh my god I would have
like Burberry eye patches well enough
about me that's my that was my saga
what's uh what's up with you what a
great advert I stuff in the new it's
been like well I'm so embarrassed that I
just told like literally this is
absolutely the most embarrassing story
I've ever told on this show but it's
also the most embarrassing thing I've
ever done like this is new for me I've
never I'm trying to learn to have casual
sex I really am because I'm in my 30s
and like I've been talking about this a
lot lately but like are you guys like
crazy horny like super just crazy like
all the time horny I love that you said
you're like I'm trying to learn to have
casual sex like it's a foreign language
you're like I'm really trying to learn
it I taught her no sex Chinese it is
hard I catch feelings when guys cuddle
me yeah I do like even that porn guy
yeah for like a little while after like
he was like let's cuddle and I was like
no kick me out and ask for your parking
pass what I need thank you and then I
won't catch feelings yeah if you don't
love me don't cuddle me kick me the [ __ ]
out just kick me out it's so much better
for me you guys like okay done done but
like I mean for most guys like women I
tell them like please cuddle me and
they're like technically I have to do
this so you still come back again I
don't know like there's this one guy
that I was hooking up with it like some
nights he would be such a cuddler he
like wouldn't get off me to the point
where they get and other nights he
wouldn't touch me at all and I always
wondered like what that meant
like why some nights he'd be like on the
other side of the bed and some nights he
cuddle me I'm like is it the girl in us
really thing I always say I analyze
reports for work and I don't analyze any
of my work reports the way that I do a
text message from a guy we're horrible
you know I haven't talked about boys the
way I do with you like even in eighth
grade when I was at the peak of my boy
craziness I talked about boys more now
that I'm like 39 and like premenopausal
yeah it's what we're dealing with you
know I had an agent come to one of my
shows a couple weeks ago he was like
Kate you know I just you're so funny but
I'd love to see you get up there and
talk about something besides like
relationships and sex and how you feel
about what you look like and I was like
that's all my life is right now like
literally I mean I'm in my 30s I'm
ravenously horny I'm trying to learn how
to have casual sex without the feelings
I want to have sex but but I barely have
sex I'm terrified of falling for people
or getting a disease or being looked at
as a [ __ ] and it's like you're I spend
all my money on Japan Way and Annabelle
might get these two sometimes I get
those free mailers for Chipotle Oh keep
them for you next time you can't
readable I mean I've never paid for sex
before I've never made four I don't pay
for dates usually I'm I fell okay I had
a moment but what do you do when a guys
like you got this how do you say no oh
you say I'm in the bathroom I'll be
right back or you say like oh let me
look at somebody or you have to check my
phone after like somebody's calling me
and you leave I didn't have my wallet no
or you saying like oh my god
you say oh I got this this is my burrito
you pay for yours and you walk out yeah
that probably would have been I mean I
would have been shocked in the moment
you were right I was shocked in the
moment I was like what is happening
maybe he's broke I I don't know his
situation I think they make good money
though right I mean they make a lot of
money the guy that I was working up with
told me he's making like at least 800
bucks a scene that's like he filmed
I bought him a burrito all right it's
fine
I didn't buy him guacamole I respect you
for that you had thanks
can we move on to you guys cuz I'm
embarrassed let's move on to you well
tell me about your dating and about I
don't really know anything about how you
date who you date I don't know either
cuz I don't I don't have the opportunity
to so it's not like I'm like I'm I'm too
shy I need to be private I don't have
this because you are you are absolutely
gorgeous you're funny I just found out
maybe you're not nice but that's what
yeah oh no not at all are you the
cheetah guy cuz they're so nice she's
she's lying she's so nice she sends me
the nicest messages of like anyone I've
ever made you I sent a some Kate like
and I honestly mean them like so but I
like I'm so detailed about them and
there's so much it's like one of those
like really long like Hallmark cards
that you like they have like 20 poems in
in them and you just like sign your name
you're like a they've put everything I'd
want to say in here they mean so much to
me but it's like I write her like such a
deep intense of her like she's going to
think that I'm like in love with which
like I totally am but it's like I wonder
if you're like on the road and creeped
out you're like why is she you know send
them at weird time she sends me messages
that like you know what in in this
business as a woman being a comedian
sometimes especially being like an
attractive woman sometimes I take a lot
of [ __ ] like that agent that came to see
me told me that I should wear
turtlenecks on stage because the
audience can't hear me when I dress like
this and I was turtlenecks I was like
where do I go to buy that 1985 but like
so many people I do I take a lot of that
from people and there are a lot of girls
that I think don't really like me
because I I can be a little like hyper
sexual and stuff sometimes in my
whatever the point is an ability they
just have dirty [ __ ] and they are
jealous of what they can't have
but you have been very super sweet I
sent her text messages like the length
of when you see somebody's phone and
it's just like this huge long paragraph
for you like they are in a huge fight
like nobody sends that long of something
but I do
obviously in this industry or in this
business and even just a seven months I
lived in LA like you don't know who's
really like a friend he's a comedy
friend and I think stuff like that
that's I'm prompt the only real thing
about me I mean so much to me we won't
stay on this topic but like I mean
seriously when I get them I'm always
just like I can't because I respect you
so much and I think you're so talented
and funny so when someone you really
respect sends you that kind of an you're
the only person to feel that way back
thank you thank you let's go back to
your dating life though so you don't
date for real no I haven't been on a
date in to like my last
and when I say relationship was like
four months and our only dates were at
McDonald's because that is all he could
afford and that's not a joke I wish it
was where did you find him the comedy
store like a comedian yeah I'm sorry I
think that I am like I'm super dick like
that I would be really judgmental about
how much money somebody makes or
anything and it's like that's not it I
don't go for looks and I clearly don't
go for money like the bottom of the
barrel and like I wonder if I could get
him like it's normally like me
approaching them and they're like yeah
yeah right they're never like oh thank
you for giving me a chance like you know
Ryan Gosling in the notebook where he's
like I'm you know just give me no I
never had somebody like threatened
suicide like hanging on a ferris wheel
I'm not asking for that but it's like I
go for such pieces of [ __ ] and so when
they acknowledge me like not like oh
thanks for when they're like yeah we're
the same type of piece of [ __ ] I guess
we could try this I'm like no for you
because you're at such a low level I
think that you'll be like oh my god
she's out of my league and my G Wagen
okay Kimmy good okay and they're like
good no so it's like we under our only
dates or at McDonald's and he would pay
for it with a gift card that his uncle
wasn't him this man was 40 by the way
hey Sam man very loosely and when our
card machine was down he was like lived
like literally like Jenga like pennies
he's like I don't and he would try to
like count out like do the fake girl
thing where you're like I'm gonna reach
for my
like take like a nickel and he'd be like
three pennies and I'm just like I got it
I hear as an embarrassed with him at
know him no he's like I don't give a
[ __ ] he's like you're lucky you're you
know you're lucky he's such an extreme
narcissist and it would I say it wasn't
even like one of those nice McDonald's
come hear something good that are nice
know that like have the bathrooms locked
up like the one I'm afraid is very nice
like they're kind of like old-fashioned
anyone it was not that it was what I
look for McDonald's locked about it's a
bathroom door has a lock on it it's
usually in a neighborhood where they
need to lock the Orcas junkies are this
one I've never seen a McDonald's have to
have their own security team it was the
worst part of Koreatown where they had
to have two security guards because
there was so much bum fighting it was
like a bum fighting the [ __ ] ring
everything for that it was a cocky in
fact just in that area
no it's like that's where like he and I
also live close to a final I was a
24-hour high hop that is bit lovely as
complimentary valet
I love the I ha you know we go can we go
there and it's so close to my like so
close my part and he's like no we're
gonna go in the one in Koreatown I was
like but that one has I don't care about
going McDonald's I love you know like no
this is my McDonald's like that was his
Cheers with me no he dumped you yeah is
he still doing comedy um I mean I would
say he was doing comedy before like
basically I aim high you guys great can
we just discuss all three of us are so
[ __ ]
why are we I'm [ __ ] porn stars who
can't afford chip Holt lay your [ __ ]
guys that are taking you to not only
McDonald's but like the one McDonald's
that you're like can we just go to one
where Harold
one where a person doesn't die like
every carry I know you're damaged like I
know the guys that you go through like
no offense but I know I know a guy who
[ __ ] stole a boogie board from your
house that's actually the better
question I don't know I thought maybe I
want to try it if you're gonna steal
something like steal the [ __ ] DVD
player he stole a boogie board I just
know what to do a favor like I mean if
he's gonna steal anything
take the boogie board it's like my lava
lamp like it's he's doing you a favor
you didn't tell me I wouldn't have
noticed why do you have a boogie board
wait he told by the water at the time I
thought maybe I'd want to take it up he
texts you like yo took your boogie board
good knowing I had to go to Vegas and so
he was like okay I'm gonna call an uber
and I was like why I have to jump in the
shower and he was like alright well I'll
probably be gone but time to get out
when I got out I was ago I texted him
because he left kid wore like a wife
beater and a shirt over it so I'm like
oh you left your shirt here and he's
like oh damn it
well by the way I took your boogie board
I was like what and then I mean yeah by
the way and bt-dubs story [ __ ] girl hang
out after that but I did see him using
it on Instagram and it looks like it's
living a good life because I'm from a
piece-of-shit town in Florida so it's
like our boogie boards like were made of
styrofoam boogie boarding just for the
just to say I hate to admit this but
like it's such a good workout and it's
so fun so like maybe but you have me in
a bathing suit k and I do have a problem
with bikinis but yeah when I boogie
board though I do where I'm like I'm
like so pro I've got like my reef fins
on I got my rash guard I wear like the
goggles you have your wax yeah you surf
wax on my boogie board just to look
legit you guys are the best
I want to keep this going forever I
talked I talked for too long on
episode guys can week no I interrupted
you first we go over by like five or ten
minutes we have okay we're gonna cuz I
want to I want to hear more from you
guys this can't be over yet we need to
first of all tell me what you're looking
for in a man my dream like what I'm
looking for in a guy is
I mean preferably if they were Jewish
but I have to be relaxed on that but we
are in Hollywood so you would think that
would be easier yeah I just want like
all I care about is that they're funny
and that they like animals and they're
polite to waiters like those are my top
three that's it like I feel like I see
how very well that attributes like
animals polite to waiters if Jewish like
if they have to be funny like I have to
have some money or here he's a comedian
but he's more of an actor and he's so
hot and he's also go frozen terrible
looking people well you the better
looking the better looking someone is
the less attracted I am to them like do
you I get intimidated yeah I'm just like
my first okay I've only had I believe
slept with two people I've only had two
boyfriends so I do such a [ __ ] no you
know I am I'm a weirdo I hey that's so
cool
no it's why is that the only no you were
the only person to use that word it's
weird and sad weird sad guys love that
you're my age you're untouched you're
basically like untouched vagina because
nobody know I'm flashing people all day
being like please touch it and they're
like no wow you've only slept with two
that's crazy have you had great sex I
mean I don't want to brag but my
gynecologist did tell me that I could
model my vagina she was like she's a 90
year old like Russian woman who should
not be practicing because she came in
she was like oh you nineteen with
cervical cancer and I was like no that's
not my shirt but thank you for thinking
about 18 which shows you how terrible is
my vagina beautiful you could model and
I was like all I heard was I could be a
model so it could be probably one of
those pamphlets for STDs like it could
be modeling for something bad like can i
take photo you're like please
I'm a free clinic that I don't know
somebody's having a model for those
right yeah me you guys watch what you
say in the oven so all right that's so
do you tell guys this when you do I mean
you must go on how do you do you know I
honestly I don't I don't date I've never
I've never been on I've been on five
dates since I've been here this is I've
lived here for six years so average in
pretty well uh would you want to go on a
date that I set you up on and then come
talk about it
sure yes I'm gonna set her up with Paul
I love that I'm gonna set her up if
you'll go out with him he's so cute well
I'm okay I don't know he was like well
it started off as a bet I was paying
group
she's pay me I was writing an article
you know what we should do I have a plan
Laney Boggs she's honest we all pick
shitty guys I pick shitty guys carry
pick shitty guys you pick McDonald's
guys so idea what we should do which
would be really fun is we should all set
each other up on a date we get to pick a
guy for the other person we all have to
go on said date and then we have to come
back on an episode and we have to talk
about the dates Oh
like are you guys down for that I am
down but who's like who's praying for
the day like I feel like it's gonna be
all of us so guys we're gonna pick guys
that's what we know : you don't get the
grog though can we go on a triple date I
mean is that too much oh my god there's
like that app have you guys been on the
what I've only lasted like tinder and
mumble I've been on them collectively
for what I lasted not even one day and I
deleted them I can't handle it but there
was like this dating app where it set
you up like you would go on a date with
it was two of your friends and then it
would be they were matched
they're like match makers and they match
you with like three guy friends and so
you guys all go out in a group date see
who hits it off so like my friend Jess I
went with Jess
Michelle oh and we had a great and my
friend Lindsay she was like she's
actively looking for relationship she
like takes this seriously
you know I me and Jessica were like
let's go have fun and like make fun of
them we used to have like our own
personal rows you know we don't want to
pay five dollars for an open-mic let's
go to this date and they were an hour
late we're engineers from Ventura so
it's not you would even date them no
it's like they're not you know
locationally hey geo divert ball if you
don't live in LA you should know that if
anyone lives more than six miles from
you you're not dating come here I mean I
it's because I love you thank you I met
the hottest guy who lives in Santa
Monica and I'm like yeah although I do
like the idea of I call it bicoastal
dating when like you live in Hollywood
and they live at the beach because then
it's kind of nice because if if I want
to be at the beach I have a place to
crash if you know I want to be in
Hollywood I have a place to crash so if
you can set it up right it's kind of
like bicoastal living getting use that
boogie board that's right
we're gonna do this we're gonna say I
only know Earl Skakel and my post mates
delivery guys I'm gonna have to it what
can't be one of them it can't be one of
them but no we're gonna figure this even
if you get them off a dating site it can
we can make this work but we're gonna do
this this is happening this is happening
and we're gonna report back happen is I
don't think it should be a triple date I
think you should have to go on a real
date
no that went terribly it was like a like
a knock off cast of the Big Bang Theory
and the fact that none of them asked for
our numbers at the end we were like sort
of like not like we were gonna go on a
date like it was like insulting that you
didn't ask like and they did not even I
have a question about this though what
did you guys like was it the kind of
thing where the matchmaker was like
you'd be good with this one you'd be
good cuz you and Sarah Jessica are so
I'm sorry Jessica Michele are so
different
yeah like our your polar opposites I
think so if you guys showed up then is
it like then you guys figure out who
fits who or how does I think it was that
the main person who's actually you know
trying to find a relationship and wants
love in their life which was Lindsay I
think she is matched up with somebody
and they're like hey bring you know two
people you to your friends
have anything going on so me and Jessica
were like us nothing
where did you meet them we met them at
it's this weird restaurant like on the
break it's like it was like a speakeasy
where you had to have like a password to
get in and I'm just like oh god it was
like a guy addressed like an old
magician at the front he's like oh that
sounds fair
that sounds fun yes yes across the key
something oh it was something where I
was like oh we're leaving he Club
because they said I know I've been there
the matchmaker would like the app sets
up the date and so they picked the place
and whatever okay Junta yeah sort of
like a less invasive anta okay I want a
Yenta so you're gonna be mine so who's
gonna you're gonna set my data up Carrie
you know me too well yeah
you're gonna set my date up I'm gonna
set up Carrie state and carries them to
set up Annabelle's date we're doing this
we're doing this guys it's happening I
know
yeah I would like just anyone with what
is your half half black athlete pro
athlete just calculated okay no but I
think what's fun about this is it
doesn't have to be my type and that's
the thing because my type clearly isn't
working and your type it would mean porn
star the old porn stars no porn stars no
comedians that's all I ask
and preferably no actors someone outside
the business how about that okay so
somebody with a jobs so with a job
Jolley employed somebody who will not
age out and never get hired again and
maybe not a fighter
because i-i've gone down the fight or
how let's try any person anybody who
could possibly have a show on HBO
whether it be real sex or gigolos okay
all right
but we unfortunately we're out of time
this is me just went by so fast you guys
just killing my ovaries we are out of
time
you guys were amazing thank you for
coming on and I can't wait to come back
and follow up with this I do we bring
the guys I we might bring the guys well
think about that we might bring the guys
if we can get them in here that would be
fantastic
chicken with Chipotle maybe I'll bring I
should have him on
I should have Chipotle guy on to defend
himself and pay you back yeah give me at
least that seven dollars where can
everyone find you guys you can find me
at my blog at adderall and compliments
calm
then my Instagram is just an avowal
desist Oh perfect
and Kari you can find me at white wine
true crime calm and I like 5-star
ratings and positive compliments if you
have nothing nice to say then just move
on to your hilarious and your Twitter is
at Kari Martin 720 to 723 birthday July
22nd I'm gonna be 40 Oh we ought to have
a big party register for that [ __ ] girl
register you're getting lips I tried to
register at cratenbarrel because I know
I'm never gonna get married or have kids
I just feel like it's fair it is fair
it's like the episode of Sex in the City
yeah yeah where she's like yo we get if
you don't get married or have kids you
never get anything you have nothing and
then so much money oh yeah friends stuff
yeah so yeah I think you should register
you should register I agree you guys you
do y'all need things you know what right
if I were you I'd register wha than
enough register for McDonald's gift
cards and give them to I need them guys
I need them guys this has been another
episode of date fails you have been
fabulous follow me at Kate cue funny on
everything and I will post a photo with
us so you can find these two lovely
ladies and if you would like to go on a
date with any one of the three of us we
will also be happy to take suitors
offline so that's what we should do so
maybe we should go out with one of you
guys so if you want to go on a date with
us tweet at me @caitstraightup